avez-vous partisans d'admettre des
femmes à l'académie française euh oui
oui oui justement mépris l'accueillir en
plein vol médias plutôt oui des noms
cités ne vendrons 9 900 seulement sur
734 immortel entré à l'académie depuis
sa création par richelieu en 1635 à
peine plus d'un pour cent des effectifs
et ne vous y trompez pas les femmes ne
sont arrivés que très récemment obtenu
madame yourcenar va voie monsieur d'or
doubs joie d'amour cela aidera à roger
caillois la première immortel de zèle
c'est marguerite yourcenar en 1981 et ce
ne fut pas une bataille facile pour la
remporter il fallut le lobbing appuyé
d'un groupe d'académiciens mené par jean
d'ormesson alors le benjamin des
immortels c'est l'oeuvre de marguerite
yourcenar qui parlent en sa faveur il ya
une longue tradition qui fait que
l'académie est une réunion d'hommes mais
aucun texte n'interdit la présence d'une
femme mais en fait la romancière elle
même ne s'était pas portée candidate
pourquoi est-ce qu'un groupe
d'académiciens a pris le risque de
provoquer une espèce de mini révolution
pour proposer votre candidature
je suppose que c'est parce qu'ils aiment
les livres selon leur seuil est
infiniment reconnaissants je trouve
assez bon qu'il sait tout de même pris
quelques risques même le reste se faire
parfois c'était en monde a l'air fab 2
gros coup c'est même ma raison
d'accepter cette irruption féminine
entraîne les résistances d'éminents
académiciens tels que claude
lévi-strauss georges dumézil ou encore
jean guitton écoutez le
les idées que
l'académie pendant 300 ans avait vécu ça
mais qu'elle pouvait encore vivre
tranquille
pire encore l'académicien pierre gaxotte
déclare en 1981 si on élisait une femme
on finirait par élire un [ __ ] misogynes
et racistes certains membres de
l'académie on trouve en tout cas dans
l'histoire de l'institution
plus de femmes recalés que reçu au moins
vingt candidates malheureuses et parmi
elles l'écrivaine chantal du pays en
vous pensez avoir quelque chance n'ont
aucune je suis lucide je suis femme mais
je sais tout le monde sait que c'est
d'académie sia soit des actifs ministre
notoire depuis ces temps troublés la
parité n'a guère évolué sur les neuf
académicienne quatre sont aujourd'hui
décédés et leurs fauteuils verts ont été
repris par des hommes un manque de
parité étonnant au regard de la réalité
des chiffres entre 2010 et 2019
notamment 42% des prix littéraires ont
été remis à des lauréates
[Musique]